[Music]
hair
can mean a lot of different things to
different people
maybe it's your pride and joy maybe it's
a chore
a clog in your drain or a symbol of your
heritage
you might grow it shave it pluck it
wax it
stress about losing it we bout to talk
about going ball
but you have to wonder what is the whole
point
well it may seem like a useless human
attribute but
hair is surprisingly pretty neat
and if you didn't have any hair
you'd have to make some changes to your
everyday life
is it natural to lose hair
what would happen when you sweat
and how would it affect your sex life
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if humans had no hair
hair changed a lot as humans evolved
while our distant chimpanzee relatives
are still covered in fur
here we are basically hairless
scientists can't fully explain why we
have
long hair on our heads short hair on our
legs and
no hair in other places but they have
theorized that we started losing hair
as we adapted to life on the hot african
savannah
without a layer of fur early hominins
could
hunt during the day without overheating
but if it was so helpful to lose fur
why do we have hair at all
before we visit the human body's major
hairy areas
let's cover the three stages of hair
growth
the anagen phase is when hair grows
about one centimeter every 28 days
some people's hair is in this active
phase for
two years while other people could be in
the anagen phase for
six years next comes
the catagen phase a transitional phase
lasting two to three weeks when growth
stops
and the hair follicle shrinks
after this happens hair can easily shed
[Music]
the final stage is called the telogen or
resting phase hair will fall off
sometime during this stage
the telogen phase lasts 100 days for the
hair on your scalp
but for your eyebrows eyelashes
arm and leg hairs this phase lasts
longer
you shed about 25 to 100 telogen hairs
every day that means you could be losing
30 000 hairs a year and it's completely
normal
but how would your life be different if
you didn't have any hair at all
let's start at the most obvious spot the
head
the hair coming from your scalp protects
the skin on your head and
sometimes your neck from sun exposure
without it you'd have a higher risk of
skin cancer
you'd have to slather your head with
sunscreen or wear a hat whenever you
went outside
head hair makes a big difference to your
appearance
if no one had any hair you'd probably
decorate your scalp with henna or
tattoos
eyebrows are another major beauty
statement but
they're more than just one of your most
distinctive facial features
they help keep sweat and rain away from
your eyes
those natural arcs divert liquid around
to the side of your face without
eyebrows your eyes would sting every
time you did a workout or
enjoyed a hot day slightly below this
are your eyelashes they act as
another shield to protect your sensitive
eyes from sand and debris
if you've ever had something stuck in
your eye you know
that even a little bit of dust can make
you
temporarily blind and because
sweat and dirt would be a constant
threat
you'd want to wear goggles whenever you
were active or outdoors
this would seal your eyes from the
dangers of the world
and that might sound ridiculous to you
right now but
think about it if everyone were hairless
it would be completely normal it could
even be a fashion statement
fancy some gucci goggles okay
let's travel on down to the most
controversial
and sometimes detested hair on the human
body
pubic hair it might seem like a nuisance
but
think of pubic hair like the eyebrow of
your genitalia it prevents
dirt debris and harmful microorganisms
from
entering that sensitive realm hair
follicles produce an
oil called sebum which stops bacteria
from reproducing
pubic hair might also trap pheromones
these scent carrying chemical secretions
affect your mood
and behavior they also send signals to
potential sex partners making you
more desirable it's
still not clear if pubic hair traps
pheromones but
if it does and you don't have any hair
down there
you'd have to try a little harder to
attract a partner
hair also reduces friction so without it
your private areas and butt cheeks could
suffer more chafing every day
if humans didn't have hair well we'd
adjust
but your life is definitely a little
easier
having the hair that you do the amount
length thickness and shape of hair is
different for each of us and beneficial
as it is
it's still just hair but
how would you adjust if your body was
different in another way
as in five meters taller
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you